[Music]
[Applause]
it's being in uh Taylor twillman the MLS
lead analyst on Apple TV he was at the
Dallas inner Miami game last night
covering Messi good to see you again
Taylor let me start with the women's
team
uh was this a matter of maybe not having
like a cohesive roster where you had
young Talent you had some older players
maybe shouldn't have been playing and
you had some injuries so and the world's
caught up a little bit here
I think it's that last Point Dan I think
that's where it is six years ago I
raised this topic and I took some real
criticism on it rightfully so to a
certain extent the fact that the United
States women they are the level that
everyone wants to chase it's completely
different versus the band we all know
that
but about six years ago I said when the
footballing soccer countries not only
put their resources behind the women's
game but their brains behind it and I'm
talking the technical tactical aspects
of the game the gap's going to be closed
there have been warning signs and with
the youth in our country and the youth
national teams struggling to get out of
groups now that generations with the
first team now we're seeing the best
most diverse U.S women's uh World Cup
ever and so now it doesn't surprise me
that the Women's World Cup now has
Canada Germany Brazil the United States
going home I think the U.S women are up
against it and I'll say this for your
listeners the definition of insanity is
doing the same thing over and over and
expecting a different result I think
this is a watershed moment for the U.S
women
well what do you mean by that
what I mean by that is they've got to
really address top to bottom how to fix
that and I think it starts with the
youth now listen
on one level and this is the ex-athlete
in me the Summer Olympics is just around
the corner so they can change the
manager they can potentially change the
general manager you can change what you
said a little bit in the roster getting
old get rid of some of that bring in
some younger players the injuries then
those players come back you can quickly
fix that at the first team level but
what I'm talking about is systemically
you've got to make sure the 14s the 16s
the 18s the 20s the 23s the rest of the
world's catching up to us Dan and if we
as a country are just relying on
athleticism and fitness we could be
behind the eight ball not only in the
next World Cup but for the next eight to
12 years I think it's a systemic issue
and I think the United States Federation
behind the women's side needs to address
that top to bottom but was the mistake
made with the roster and maybe you know
keeping some of these you know Mount
Rushmore women on the team and they
shouldn't have been on the team
yes absolutely now if you're gonna have
them on the team they better be really
good in Dynamic and Leadership and I
think there's a debate to be had there
listen Carly Lloyd took a lot of
criticism and I defended Carly Lloyd Dan
you know this way better than me many
athletes leave the field get into this
job the red light comes on they don't
want to say anything they don't really
want to give their opinion because
they're scared about their friendships
or relationships off the field Carly
Lloyd gave her opinion whether I agree
or disagreed that's not here but she's
the closest thing we have in the media
to that group and she wanted to bring up
mentality she wanted to bring up
leadership
I gotta listen to that Dan if I'm gonna
listen to anyone and so I think there's
a real good argument that they relied on
reputation versus repetition and I think
it may have caught up to him
and it's a polarizing team
I didn't know I didn't realize how Paul
I forgot how polarizing they were to a
certain segment of of America and and
there were there were people celebrating
the UN I don't remember a U.S team
playing on a big stage in any sport
where we reacted or people reacted that
way like yeah good I'm glad go home
why
because that's the world we live in now
Dan I mean listen I honestly I've never
seen a red white and blue team rooted
against as much as the U.S women and
it's equal pay it's diversity it's the
fact that Megan rapino was the first
athlete to back Colin Kaepernick and
support him when she knelt they then
it's the cameras all over them they're
not singing the National Anthem now
there is polarizing as any group that
that may be there now I I'm of the
mindset on a personal level
they're also sticking up for what they
believe and I have no issue with that
but you've got to deliver now I raised a
real question I don't care if they're
men or women you are two-time defending
world champion and if you come into a
stadium and dancing and singing you're
bringing more attention to yourself than
is needed you're already the two-time
world champion you don't need that you
didn't see the French national team come
into the 22 World Cup dancing and
singing on the men's side now I
criticize that now all of a sudden Dan
I'm called the bigot that's just the
world we live in now and so I am very
confused in the world we live in because
the women that we're talking about the
Hope solos the Carly Lloyds they've told
me off camera and behind the scenes we
need people like you to criticize us
analyze us the way you do men Dan when I
do that I'm now called the bigot I'm now
called a sexist and so your aunt you're
asking me I don't know really what the
answer is but I do know this is one of
the if not the most polarizing teams in
the World of Sport make no mistake about
it Taylor twillman the MLS lead analyst
on Apple TV he was at the Dallas
intermiami game where Messi had a couple
of goals simplify his greatness if you
can
uh buddy I can't but I I said this
during the game Dan I think you'll
appreciate this but Taylor I I liken him
to Steph Curry it doesn't make sense oh
he's bigger than that no no no what
Steph Curry Well Steph Curry changed the
game of basketball he's undersized he
doesn't jump he's not quick he's not
strong you know exactly what's what's
coming
yeah I can look at Messi and go that guy
is the best player now I know it's
against MLS competition but still
I I there's something about him that he
does something in a different way than
anybody else who plays the sport what is
it yeah now Dan you say it's against MLS
competition by the way he did this at
the World Cup against the best players
in the world six months ago that's he's
different what I said in this broadcast
last night and by the way I slept right
there for three and a half hours because
I couldn't sleep anyways because of what
happened last night the truth is this
there's only four athletes that when the
occasion comes and the expectation level
is there they super they they exceed
those Michael Jordan Tiger Woods
Muhammad Ali Steph Curry's not one of
those guys he's changed basketball but
he has failed Lionel Messi Dan every
single time the moment comes and you say
there's no way whether it's the World
Cup when he's 35 whether it's inner
Miami where he's had maybe four
trainings with the team it's
unbelievable how every single time he
delivers and then some I don't know if
we've ever had an athlete in this sport
pelay was one in a million
I'd say Johan Cruyff Diego Maradona but
they didn't do it as long as he's doing
it he's 36 Dan and still operating at a
level that very few if any have ever
operated at have you ever been in a
friendly against him
I've actually played in a real
competition 2007 Copa America we played
in Venezuela we were up one nil 25
minutes later we lost 4-1
what was the scouting report on Messi
back then do you remember and that's the
bet I'm actually glad you asked that
because that was 2007. he hadn't done
he's done seven time Ballon d'Or winner
right he hasn't done any of that I I
likened him to this and I remember
remember when Michael Vick made his
introduction to college football and I
forget the defender did the linebacker
from the Florida State team that played
him but he compared him to a chicken on
a farm and you run around trying to
chase the chicken with the chicken with
his head cut off Lionel Messi walks he
walks more than any other player and yet
I likened him he's five seven 150 pounds
he's like the water bug on top of the
lake water that just bounces everywhere
and you think you got him you got him
you try to hit him you slap him you
can't touch him he's easy to find he's
the easiest guy right now to see on the
field and say hey he's number 10 he's in
a pink jersey app absolutely kick the
snot out of him and Dan no one cans it
it's honestly Dan it's the most
remarkable trait the best ability is
availability he's never seriously been
hurt that is amazing to me
and he doesn't flop either uh no no
which I I respect that but I liken him
to the same thing as Steph Curry it's
like when uh raindrop goes down your
windshield and you have and then it just
takes a hard left and then it'll take a
hard ride and then it keeps go straight
and then it's a left
that's
that would be my comparison that Messi
is like that rain drop going down your
windshield just like Steph Curry some
things you can't explain but that's the
beauty of of sports
nope but Messi's got two quads on him
that buddy that raindrop has about 17
raindrops on each leg because you can't
knock them off the ball uh and you you
faced him when he was 20. yeah I know
that's it thanks for dating me Dan I
appreciate that yeah yeah wow awesome
how would you do against him now
I'd be in the hospital after about 30
seconds
uh great to talk to you again Taylor
thank you yeah great seeing you but uh
Taylor twillman uh MLS lead analyst on
Apple TV and uh there to witness Messi
last night